هو أن كل الدخان المنبعث من الإطارات يمكنك أن
ترى أنه تم نشر قوات الأمن
عبر
طرق العاصمة تم حظرها ، وتم إغلاق الإنترنت
ومحور وسائل الإعلام
مقيد بشدة جميع الحرائق التي نريد
بلدًا يمكننا العيش فيه لقد مضى 16
عامًا على هذا الشاب  يصرخ الرجل بأنني
خريج جامعي
ليس لديه عمل ، العديد من
المتظاهرين هم شباب البلاد
الذين ترتفع نسبة البطالة بينهم بشكل
خاص ، يقول رجل آخر هنا إنه
درس القانون ، والعمل الوحيد الذي وجده هو في
صالون لتصفيف الشعر يقول إنه كان
يثبته  لعدة أيام ، كانوا يصرخون على
بعضهم البعض حول استخدام الحكومة
للقوة ، وأصدقائهم الذين قُتلوا
في المظاهرات ، والظلم الذي يصوره هذا
الرجل الذي لا يريد
الكشف عن هويته منذ
البداية ، لا يوجد شيء
تعتقد أن الناس لم يهاجموه.  أن
قوات الأمن هيمنتها من
المضحك أن سلاحنا الوحيد كان
جسديًا حتى لا تتمكن قوات الأمن من
دفع شيطان المتظاهرين  ds ليس
غير معقول ، كما يقول ، ويوفر الجمع
فرص العمل ويحسن الخدمات الأساسية ،
لكن الاحتجاجات أصبحت أكثر عنفًا ،
مما يهدد الأمن الهش بالفعل في هذا البلد
،
وقد أثار ارتفاع عدد القتلى غضب أولئك الذين يحاولون النزول
إلى الشوارع ، هذا الفيديو منذ اليوم
الثالث عندما كان هناك  لا يزال حظر التجول
ساريًا ، من الصعب حقًا النظر إليه
نظرًا لوجود رجل على الأرض
مصاب بجرح في الرأس ، أصبح صوت
إطلاق النار ثابتًا بعد بضع
دقائق شوهد رجل آخر ينزف من
جرح طلق ناري يقول كل ما يريدون  هو
أن تسمع أوقف القتل ، يتوسل
استمع إلى ما يريدون ، أرسل شخصًا
من الحكومة ليقول إنني هنا
لأتحدث إليكم ما الذي تعرفه
عن نقطة محورية في بغداد للمظاهرات
محاطة بحلقة أمنية
العاصمة متوترة على حافة الهاوية
الحكومة تطالب بالهدوء وتعهدت
بالتصدي للمطالب المتظاهرين
بوعود سمعها السكان من قبل
لكن الكلمات الجوفاء لن تخنق بعد الآن.
غضب الشعب